and you're like dude i believe in you if
you were just gonna start a new startup
i'm in for 25k like no questions asked
yeah
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off on the road let's
travel never looking back all right
everyone we have a new episode this one
was pretty good so we talked about a
couple things
the first thing we talked about was
oasis which is this interesting new
product that
kind of uh it's like a deep fake but for
zoom
that's not the best subscription but
check it out sean says it's one of the
biggest ideas that he's ever heard of
second we break down the sweepstake
business if you want to make a company
that makes like half a million dollars a
month in profit
and you want to have it start and launch
inside the next probably two years like
uh or sorry two months and then grow in
the next one two
three years to half a million dollars a
month and profit i think this is an
interesting idea we break it down
and then we talk about sean's prediction
so he predicts what's going to be the
next apple
facebook amazon 711 netflix pornhub
dominoes those are all
separate predictions not one company can
do all of them but that would be cool
and uh it's a great episode
give it a listen and by the way have you
clicked subscribe yet on new on youtube
and have you clicked subscribe on itunes
a lot of people say like hey you guys
are awesome thank you for doing all that
work
then pay me back i i don't want money
though all i
all i want is for you to hit subscribe
on itunes hit follow on spotify
hit subscribe on our youtube page that's
all i want and we're going to keep doing
it for free
all right let's get to the episode um
what's going on
i am uh look at me now i'm in my i'm in
a chick palace here
what's a chick palace i mean like i went
from like a manly industrial look
to like everything is glitter and gold
now yeah that doesn't look like your
style
that doesn't even look like it's your
wife's style yeah i don't know who style
this is but that's the style we got
today
have you ever thought about creating a
uh
brick and mortar business by the way oh
wait actually first
two things two things before we get into
anything everybody like and subscribe
and tell a friend
tell five friends yes but um
wednesday do we have a guest on
wednesday i don't think so
okay uh yes we do oh okay damn it okay
not this wednesday
on monday after that let's do the
investor episode we have another yes
we have a guest on monday too yeah dan
held is coming out on monday all right
so we got two guests
okay then we're gonna do it fine didn't
forget that second thing
i have this episode coming out you know
i've been doing these monday things
yeah so what i'm doing is i'm splicing
together clips
i'm gonna splice together like five to
ten and i'm gonna talk in between each
one and each clip is gonna be from a
youtube video or from a podcast
and the topic is uh i'm i'm
i'm obsessed with time right now because
i'm quite impatient and i'm trying to
work on it
and the topic is on actually patience
and how like great things that i admire
actually took much longer than i thought
right and so you so what what is okay so
if i listen to this episode what am i
gonna get i'm gonna get sam talking
about
time yeah and you gotta turn your mic
down a little bit um no so what you're
gonna get is you're going to get me
um so you all right so uh
travis kalanick before he started uber
he had this thing called red swoosh you
know what that was
uh i don't even know what it did but
i've heard the story i don't even know
what it did either to be honest it was a
peer-to-peer
it was like it's not relevant anymore
because it was like napster but it was
like napster but different
and he sold it for like 20 million
dollars but it took like eight years or
something like that like crazy
and i and i found that i have this
amazing
youtube um video of him giving a talk
like a 40-minute talk but like the first
like three minutes is about red swoosh
and it's like
he explains how hard it was i'm like oh
my god that took forever and i've got
like eight or nine of those clips that
i've saved of people admire
saying they're gonna take a lot it's
taking a long time and i'm putting them
together
so it's a however long the podcast is
going to be with like two to three
minute clips with me like
making it give you the background of
each story right okay
uh i like it so we'll see if it's
interesting so have you ever seen um
the joe rogan thing where it's like joe
joe rogan watches the internet or
something like that have you ever seen
these youtube videos
no but is it good yeah they're funny
it's like
it's a compilation of basically joe
watching youtube videos and just
reacting to them
uh but all the videos are really
interesting kind of like random ass
stuff from the internet
and then his reaction is like good he's
not trying to be like super over the top
it's like his genuine
genuine reaction to it so i kind of see
this as like the business version of
that
where you're taking one theme and then
you see what a bunch of different
interesting people have said about that
theme and it's sort of like sam surfs
the internet where you're gonna like
kind of go into and out of each of those
clips and just be talking
we'll see if it's any good so in in over
the next couple days if you
have an example of a talk that you've
listened to
or a story that amazed you send it to me
okay sounds good by the way you said
something about travis atlantic have you
ever read this blog post he did
called like um how to do south by
southwest on a budget or something like
that you know what i'm talking about
yeah so he had this old c yes maybe
which i do
which i don't even think you could find
in a blog anymore and
he basically wrote like uh you know if
you show up at this time you can get
free this
uh you can get a discounted cab if you
do x y and z
right yeah like he was like being pretty
scrappy and like saving like pitching
pennies right
yeah exactly it was i think it was like
ces or south by southwest and he was
basically like
yo if you're going to these things
here's how to do it like here's how to
ball out on a budget
and then he had all those little like
tips and tricks of like
you don't need to get vip pass to go
here just wear like an orange vest and
then you could walk through
you know that type of thing yeah he was
like scrappy
yeah so i was just listening to this
podcast
uh theo von the theo von podcast i don't
even know what it's called
and he had the founder of raising canes
on there do you know what raising canes
is
yeah dude i've met the founder of raisin
canes at a random i was at a table i was
eating lunch one day and
the founder was was right next to me and
you just said uh
what's up or i mean yeah i was like hey
well you know this is kind of like this
old it was a it was a restaurant
conference so it wasn't like super
random
uh but there's just kind of this nice
all nice you know like slightly older
southern guy uh i think he was the owner
of the fountain of the ceo
um well there's two guys who started it
one of them is about 50 but he looks
quite young maybe it's the other guy
and i was listening to this podcast with
him he's southern lives in louisiana
and they have hundreds of restaurants at
this point and north of a billion
dollars in sales
and he the way that he makes makes it
sound he's like i just loved running the
fryer i loved being at the place
it sounds so much and the grass is
always greener it sounds so much more
fun than sitting behind a computer
have you ever thought about doing this
what way well how is that more fun
sitting
have you ever been in a restaurant back
you know like the back that kitchen of a
restaurant
next to the family i was i was like
shitty i was a bus boy
i was a bus boy and i i i was never old
enough to be a waiter but yeah i worked
in the service industry
it is fun just like being in the being
being in the action it just sounded cool
so would you ever do a brick and mortar
or like a i did and i regretted every
second of it um
you know the the part that is fun
actually is the camaraderie because
that's what i'm saying the kitchen crew
this the bond is different than like
just your normal friends or like your
co-workers like if you go to your office
today
and you have a co-worker who sits you
know three desks down and both you have
your headphones on
and you're typing on your mac you know
you have and you go to you go get your
free lunch together at the cafeteria
like this is the tech industry right
it's like totally different vibe than
you're in the restaurant it's friday
night the restaurant's rocking you're
banging out orders as fast as you can
and you um you know it's 1am when you're
finally done cleaning up and it's like
all right now let's go eat
and then you know you go to some
restaurant and the restaurants close but
they let you in because you're from the
restaurant industry and you get to go
eat with them like that's just a
different
level of comrade yeah that's what i'm
saying it's exciting it's fun you're in
the thick of it i love it
yeah but i would never want to do it
again it's like it's like you know when
people are like yeah
going to the army was one of my most uh
you know formidable times it's like
would you ever want to go back again
through that boot camp through hell week
again like just so you know i've i read
this book called
tribe and it's all the because i was
curious about what type of neighborhood
would be best to live in and like what
makes
what makes you happy when finding a
place to live and it's a it's
you know i don't know this i've never
been in the military but
so i know from like an academic story
point of view that when you're in the
military a lot of guys
a huge amount of guys when they get out
they
miss it like crazy because they're like
all right it was hard i was risking my
life yeah that's true
but i felt like i had a crew of guys we
were always doing something i had a
mission and
i and life is so lame and boring without
it yeah i i could see that
but um also there's a lot of people when
you talk to him it's like man that was
the best and hardest time my life
would i go back and do it again no i
don't want to do it again but it was an
amazing time at that time
and uh you know this sort of like when
astronauts come back from space is what
you're describing it's like
yeah they're kind of like well now what
i you know i freaking went to the moon
that was my life mission and now every
day seems quite
boring and like you know uneventful and
not not really having a purpose as i did
before um
but anyways i guess like brick and
mortar so what you know what would you
want to do if you were doing brick and
mortar
i think i could crush a i think i could
i could i could operate
a hotel or a restaurant really well
hospitality
yeah i think i could crush that and i
and maybe i will want to do that one day
i
but i think i can kill it i'm looking at
buying another house and turning it into
a rental
um because i already did it with this
one um
and i'm seeing one later today but i
think i could crush it
and what uh okay okay uh so i was gonna
say what was theo vaughn talk about so
theo von was just
he just interviewed the guy okay gotcha
um all right
yeah i wouldn't uh i'm more like even
with e-commerce i'm like ah
this business is great except for all
the physical products like
you know right now there's a situation
going on
where um i think i forgot what the exact
tweet is but it's sort of like
the there's boats or you know everyone
saw that that one boat got stuck in the
canal
yeah like feeling you're like feeling
the the pain now
well it's not really that there's just
like another situation where the biggest
port in china
is backed up and uh they're just like
there was a covet outbreak and so for a
week
they were operating at 30 capacity and
this is like the biggest
throughput uh like logistics place in
um in the world and so the knock-on
effects of that
are gonna like last i don't know like
months basically and so basically what
you're seeing now is that
boats couldn't get out on time they were
just idling in the water
and uh brian peterson who we're gonna
have on the pod because he tweeted this
out he goes
you know it's crazy the average you know
wait time now or the average number of
boats that's waiting is blah blah and i
asked him i go i tweeted back i said
what's the cost per day of that boat
just sitting idle right with all this
cargo on
top and just sitting in the water not
being unloaded and he did the math he's
like it's about a million dollars a day
that the shipping company is losing just
by being stuck and then for all the
downstream people like you know if i
have my goods on a [__]
on a boat that's not here well now i'm
delayed now i'm out of inventory and
because i'm out of inventory i'm out of
sales and there's just
one after another sort of like knock-on
effects of this and so
for me even e-commerce which is pretty
pretty like internety is uh like the you
know the only bad part about it is all
these physical goods like oh
you had a product but then uh the wheels
are broken or the zippers are the
customer's
understanding of that at all like like
when i like i'm so
now i do amazon you know two day
delivery one day delivery whatever it is
but if something it comes like in seven
or ten days i think i'm mostly cool with
it right
um maybe uh during covid
people were understanding because it was
just like dude it's covered like
everything is
backed up and if this is not like a
mission critical thing
then uh you know then i understand
but like people's kind of covered
patients wore off i think
and um and also if not everything is
backed up it's just your stuff
then you look really bad and you know
business even if it's not
even if they understand like you lose
sales and losing like two weeks of sales
is like pretty devastating for your
month's revenue which is like you know
uh pretty bad for your your annual
revenue when you're operating on like 10
15 percent ebitda
and so so yeah by the way the tweet was
five and a half percent of the world's
container fleet is waiting outside of a
port
and then he said i asked what is the
cost per day to be waiting idle he goes
one trip round trip from asia on
one of these shipping boats is 50
million of profit so every every
day that they're sitting out you know
sitting sitting idle and it's a 30 day
trip
and so you know so that's about a
million dollars per day per ship
that's idle and then i was like holy
[__] these ships make 50 million in
profit for a single
round trip from asia and uh and then you
know people are replying people who know
about the shipping industry they're like
yeah it's crazy like
the top um the top 10 shipping companies
will make like 100 billion in profit
this year
um but like in the last 10 years they've
lost 100 billion in profit like
it's it's a very volatile volatile
funnel space based on you know volumes
and costs and all the stuff like right
now a shipping container is
twice as much as it was last year just
because supply demand is so out of whack
that's crazy i'm excited to have him on
and so we'll nerd out with him about
that
so you want to talk about some ideas we
have a bunch here we where where do you
want to start
so some of the some of the ideas that i
wrote down so i wrote down two i think i
said i have
i have three one is oasis which i think
is one of the biggest startup ideas most
most interesting startup ideas out there
uh nuggs which isn't the fake chicken
nugget market and i have some thoughts
around that
and then i have a prediction section
where i'm gonna predict what the next
facebook
amazon google and netflix will look like
and so
uh those are my uh actually i have
another one but maybe we'll save that
one for the next pod so those are my
three you could do today
let's do oasis carp oasis
giveaway business and predictions
all right sounds good so oasis so you
know what this is but i think most
almost everybody 99 of people listening
to this have no idea what this is
so let me explain the the concept i um
i'll tell the story of how i bumped into
this guy i was on twitter and i saw this
guy matt
and he was teasing kind of like you know
people do this on twitter where they
have like
my stealth thing is kind of coming or
they post a screenshot or like a gif
it's kind of ambiguous but it looks
interesting it looks provocative or
they're just retweeting people i think
this is what i saw
he had retweeted our mutual friend sikhi
who was like
dude just got an oasis demo mind blown
this is the future
and so he retweeted that and i'm like
okay hook line and sinker
like tell me about like how do i get
that demo i also would like my mind
blown
and he's like all right yeah hop into
zoom so i hopped into a zoom
and he showed me something that was
honestly pretty mind blowing
and what it was was he was like okay so
i'm talking to you on zoom right now
here's my face and um but you know the
problem with zoom is that you always got
to look good
uh and people get you know people get um
nervous about that and so you know over
60 of people don't actually
turn their camera on in north america
because they're self-conscious of how
they look
and um that kind of sucks so now we're
video calling without the video right
and he's like so what if instead you
could have a representation of you
that wasn't like cartoony it's not like
an emoji or an animoji or whatever the
apple thing is
it literally looks like you and we'll
show a screenshot of this
um on the screen if you're watching on
our youtube channel which is just
youtube.com
hustlecon you'll see the video of this
it's kind of amazing
so the video the gift that i want to
show is it says never worry about how
you look on camera again
and it's a video of the founder matt
he's in the shower holding up his phone
and on the left side is what he actually
looks like it's a dude in the shower
um and on the right side is like the
digital representation of it it's him
but he doesn't look like he's in the
shower he looks like him like in front
of a perfect backdrop
just talking and it's tracking his mouth
perfectly and um
so i thought oh this is kind of amazing
like if i could be on video without
actually having to be on video if i
could
kind of like a filter but if i could
just automatically have the best looking
version of myself on camera
god that would save me a lot of time and
energy and thought around how i look
and he's like it gets even better so not
only
does it let you do that you could also
show up as a different person so say
you're you know
a minority you don't want to be
discriminated against you could you
could show yourself as
you know a tall white male and nobody
would ever know what you actually look
like so this empowers like
working synonymously which is something
we've talked about the last thing is
he's like here's the best bit this works
on like the worst connections
uh worst connection phones in the world
i said well how do you do that it seems
like pretty high powered he goes
there's no video being transferred i
said what he goes
yeah it's like a video game the screen
on my side is tracking my face
every pixel of my face how my lips are
moving my nose my eyes etc
and then instead of sending my video
across the internet it just sends
how those pixels are moving like a video
game and so then on the other side it
recreates the video
just using those pixel coordinates and
so the idea here is that
even on really shitty internet low
bandwidth scenarios you could have
awesome looking video and without you
having to like you you could be rolling
out of bed and you look like a million
bucks so what do you think of this idea
i think i was pitched this as well
and i passed did you
did you pass or no uh yeah i didn't even
really get
i i have a call schedule with the guy i
just saw the demo this was months and
months ago it wasn't like in an
investable spot at that moment
um or like they weren't raising or
something like that but
i'm looking at it now you know it does
have a higher valuation and you know
it's pretty
it's got a very high valuation i i don't
know are we
is i don't let's not say okay um
it's got a high valuation um and it's
like
six guys working on this it's pretty
wild
and i so here's what here's what i think
about this i think
the way the way that it's set up now is
not the way that it could be a huge
thing okay
and what you mean so a lot of times when
i either invest in stuff or i want to
get involved in a project whether i'm
starting it or not
i'm very comfortable taking the leap of
faith of saying
this is just how i'm gonna start and i'm
very comfortable in saying one of two
things
i know how it's going to end or rather
like i want to create a massive media
company that covers this this and this
i'm going to start with an email i don't
know the middle ground but i'm
i'm pretty confident i'm going to figure
it out or
i'm also okay with not even having an
ending point
of like i created something cool it
feels powerful and strong
yeah i think i could figure it out where
to go and this
business i think was that second one so
i saw the technology
i played with it i got the demo and he
basically was talking to me and
i i got it i was like oh okay so like to
me this is like pretty
like unlimited unlimited on what the
options are and so the bet i'm having to
make
is is this founder great and can they
figure out exactly how to
deploy this technology and
i wasn't sure if i i wasn't sure if it
was worth trying to figure out if they
could get it
yeah well also the price matters right
so like that's why i'm saying
you don't want to pay a i figured it out
price when they haven't figured it out
yet
right you want to pay the oh this is
cool and promising price
which should be like 10 times lower uh
but i get why this has a high valuation
because to me
you see something like zoom zoom is a
100 billion dollar company
zoom is letting you call um you know do
do video calls with people
all around the internet for business
purposes i think that the future zoom
like the leapfrog of zoom is not
zoom with slightly better features or
the recording is better the audio
quality is a little better it's
this is a video call where i don't
actually have to be on video but it
looks like i'm on video
everybody looks great everybody's
presenting their professional self
regardless of how they actually look at
home and secondly
this works on extremely low bandwidth
shitty internet
uh circumstances because it's not even
transferring video it's just
transferring pixel coordinates
that to me is like a leapfrog and that
means what does
if zooms 100 billion today and somebody
built what i believe if you did this it
would be a better zoom
um obviously doesn't have the network
effects doesn't have the brand doesn't
have many things that you need to do to
get it big but it has
the magic trick and i think when you
have a magic trick you can get a lot of
users pretty quickly
and the magic trick here is pretty
impressive we were both pretty impressed
with the magic but it sounds like we're
saying the same thing but i guess my
difference would be
i think i know what the endpoint looks
like the endpoint looks like this is how
business calls are done
you have your dude that's not that big
is that that big of a market
i don't i disagree with you i don't know
man if i was this i'd be using this for
movies or
for you know i actually don't even know
what i would use it for but i can't
imagine business calls would be the
number one thing
dude zoom is massive zoom is like
humongous right 100 billion dollar
company how much bigger do you want
right one trillion
okay you can get to a trillion but this
you're not making zoom this is a plug-in
for zoom
i think you could make the new zoom
using this right why would i use
zoom when instead i could use this where
i always look like a million bucks
already it's better than zoom and the
second thing is it works better on any
internet conditions because
it's not transferring heavy video across
the wire regardless
i'm into this i'm into this i just was
unwilling to bet my own money at that
high of evaluation
yeah i think that's totally fair uh the
the reason this stuck out to me was i
was like
i had this doc i've talked about before
which is called the biggest idea in my
head right now
which is basically if i was totally free
i could drop everything i was doing and
i was going to work on
the biggest startup idea in my head at
any given month what is it and i just
keep track month by month and sometimes
it's the same for two months straight
three months straight
and sometimes it changes this became the
biggest
startup idea in my head because i think
it's basically taking novel technology
going after a really big market and it's
doing it in a way that is like complete
like the incumbents would have to sort
of re-architect their whole [__]
to be able to do this i think i don't
think you could just make a plug-in to
do this and so
um so anyways i thought this was like
one of the bigger ideas so i just wanted
to bring it up i don't really have any
more besides that
all right let's move on then you want to
talk about something that's way less
of a big idea but a surefire way to make
a lot of money
yes okay let's talk about the giveaway
business
also known as the sweepstake business
and i'm interested in this business
because well because i've used it a lot
because it seems easy and awesome and
you've done it you've dabbled
yeah so with the hustle one way that we
we grew
we grew in a bunch of ways but we did
two things that are related to this
the first we would pay companies
or i'll start with this one the first we
would give stuff away
we would give a tesla away we would give
a 3d printer away which we're giving now
and if you share an email or you get
other people to join
like and they use your unique url you
get more entries
and if a car costs us 30 000 and we
acquire
30 000 emails that's a dollar to acquire
an email that's a really good deal for
us
because we make let's say 10 off every
email no brainer
the second thing that we did is we paid
some of these companies and i want to
explain how they work so do me a favor
and go to bold.org
can you do that right now okay i'm on it
what's this fighting student debt
that's it yeah and how does it say it
does it
um let's see so scholarships
philanthropy
i don't know it just looks like
donations or something like that right
so what you do and
because they may get all click um
scholarships for
uh nursing or something okay uh
scholarship for nursing students i'm
there
five great scholarships for future
nurses great all right
so bold.org what they do is they go and
they get
they they either create scholarships or
they find people
uh who uh have scholarships and they
aggregate
it into one area into one platform
not that hard to do and it's in itself
then what they do is they go get
loads of people to sign up for the
scholarship so they advertise to nurses
and nursing facebook groups on google
and they get people to sign up and and
enter all this information
um and here's how they make money when
you are a nurse
or let's say you're uh applying to get
your mba if you have
tens of thousands of people apply to get
their an mba scholarship
that's a pretty cool pretty high
qualified lead list right right
same with nurses same with i mean pretty
much any of these niches
and what they do is as you sign up for
this thing at the end they go also do
you want to opt in for this
this or this or this and companies like
the hustle i would pay them money i
think at one point we were paying them
maybe 50 to 100 a month and that's how
many leads that they were getting us
that's amazing so so basically they go
they pay for so they they go and they
spend money to get people to apply for a
scholarship and people are like oh
fantastic thank you so much
and then when they're applying they're
basically like hey would you like to opt
in now why does a person want to opt in
or is it like hey
do this and you get some increased odds
of the scholarship or how does it work
i believe both yeah so like they just
like show offers that are interesting
and also uh i believe it's just like
it's you're automatically in unless you
opt out
in the flow and you get more likelihood
if you opt into stuff
dude how did you even find this how did
you think oh you know what i'm gonna go
like when you you were trying to make
the connection between sweepstakes and
giveaways and you're like
go to bull.org this like non-profit
looking
you know scholarships for nurses in
africa i was like what does this have to
do with
how did you even figure out this is how
you grow an email so i'll
there's a bunch of ways that i know how
to do this the first there's this guy
named dennis gross who we're gonna have
to get on this podcast so dennis started
wisegeek which you and i are both
probably too young to have used it but
it was like a web 1.0 thing
it made a lot of money and then he
started loads of other things including
uh investing into lots of different
startups like thumbtack but then he
started bestreviews.com do you remember
that
or do you know what best reviews.com is
it sold for 160 million dollars the
tribune
like three or four years ago so this guy
named dennis he's very very wealthy and
he started loads of companies and he
stays way below the radar
and he created this thing called
mechanism which is like an idea lab
except he's like an seo guru and like a
lead gen guru so he's launched all these
companies and the co-founder of
mechanism is
brendan who's the founder of toptal and
i'm friends with both of those guys and
i saw what they're getting into
and he pitched me and sold me on using
bold.org and it was pretty good
right so that's first i can't find this
guy dennis gross
is that his name go to bold.org about
he spells his name d-i-n-i-s space
g-r-o-s-z gotcha
okay so he's oh he actually did bold
okay so that's how you found out
so here's where here's here's what i'm
getting at here so
this got me interested into giveaways
actually you have to call them
sweepstakes there's a lot of legality
around this
and so what what i learned was you and
we when we
did sweepstakes we would have to call it
sweepstakes you have to have rules that
are approved by your lawyer
and i got kind of interesting it's like
uh you could buy entries or if you just
mail us this form we have to let you
apply we have to give you the equivalent
entry right so it's like there's all
types of technicalities here you can't
make it but pay to play otherwise it's
like a lottery or
and you can't uh yeah it can't be a
lottery you can't now i don't
this is just an example i don't know if
this is actually the rule you can't use
the word like free
or you can't do like there's a bunch of
like technicality stuff that you have to
follow
but i got in uh very interested in
giveaways and so i did some research on
a bunch of them so there's
loads of giveaway businesses the there's
uh three ways that i've seen it work
the first you buy entries so i've seen
um
like buythishouse.com i believe it's
called
or buy buy san francisco home.com where
a company buys a san francisco house
then they put ads all over the subway
they put ads all over the billboard and
they sell entries for a hundred dollars
and it's a raffle
the second way that this business works
is you do it bold
bold did which is the audience is the
product and you sell their information
uh you know those cars that are at malls
yeah okay so what happens at those
businesses is they
they pay them all the uh a marketing
part company pays the mall
a rental fee to use that real estate
space right yeah
then loads of people enter their
information to join and buy that car
they look at the all the leads and names
now that they have the birth date things
like that
and they categorize them and then they
sell them to different companies and
those companies
cold call those people to sell them x y
and z right
okay so the third way that you make
money off of this
is you can sell merch and when you sell
merch you get
x more entries into the giveaway and i
found this one company that's doing car
giveaways
and i got a hold of these financials and
if you're listening to this actually
there's a
the takeaway here is that this about
this business but the second takeaway is
sign up for brokerage website that that
sell
that's amazing yeah an amazing way to
learn you go to quiet light brokerage
you go to what's the name of this one
yeah you go to flippa empire flippers
you quiet light brokerage you can go to
like
one of many uh oh you know fe
international or whatever
there's a whole bunch of places where
you can go and you can basically look at
internet businesses the beauty of it is
if you want to if you're on the outside
you're like dude i've never actually
been inside of a successful business
i've never run one never owned one
never sold one you can go on here and
it's a great way to get business ideas
because you're just going to see a bunch
of business you never thought about like
oh
these guys sell you know you know it's a
d2c
diabetes brand they sell you know
products for diabetic diabetic patients
and they're doing 8 million a year of
revenue 4 million of
profit and here's their top three skus
and here's how they grow
and here's their p l because they're
trying to sell their business so they
had to package
everything up and make it a book that
you can go look at as a buyer
the beauty of the online ones is they
don't know if you're a serious buyer or
if you're a 21 year old kid just trying
to learn about business
and so i've looked through probably
hundreds of these at this point
um just to learn right so that's like
how i feed my business brain is
is one of these one of the tactics is to
go look at businesses that are for sale
and read their books
so i was interested in sweepstakes and
just so happened i saw one for sale and
i went and found this one
so here's the sweepstakes and what they
do if you google car sweepstakes
i'm not going to say the name of the
company very likely they come up on the
top 10 of google
on the front page so i am just off that
i imagine they're one of the big dogs
did you go uh google card
right now yep i see them okay um and
the last 12 months revenue was 26
million seven hundred thousand dollars
the last 12 months of net profit
was 5.8 million dollars and
in this document that i have there's
like a q a where someone's just asking
them questions and they explain how it
works and what it works is they have a
warehouse
and they have like 30 employees all
warehouse workers mostly
and you they run ads on let's just say
let's say this is for a car one they run
ads
and sponsored videos on youtube car chat
car youtube channels and before the guy
shows off his car he goes by the way
this one
is sponsored by blank company they're
giving away a car if you want the car
click the link below you go to that link
and it says great you're gonna
be entered to win this car by the way if
you buy this sweatshirt for forty
dollars you're gonna get
ten more entries if you buy this hat
you're gonna get
x amount more entries and so they make a
profit off of
it's just an e-commerce store basically
right and
it's amazing i mean i don't i don't
think it's actually sketchy i think
that's a
you're kind of preying on vulnerable
people a bit and they said that in this
document
that the person one time or first of all
the repeat customer rate is 50
so 50 of people who sign up for one
eventually do another
and they have guys that will spend eight
thousand dollars on merch in order to
get more entries into these cars
wow yeah it's it's this is definitely
one of those where it's pretty
polarizing you know some people will say
this is
this is shady this is messed up um i
find it
fascinating that a business like this
even exists 25 million a year in revenue
5 million a year in profit and uh very
very simple business you know what i
mean
like and if this is what i call like you
got to know how
internet plumbing works they're like oh
okay i can plug a pipe into youtube
and uh that gives me a lead and then
with the lead i plug that into an
e-commerce store
and that gives me this and then i'll
plug into this like sweepstakes law that
will allow me to do this legally
and i've seen the same thing by the way
in the gun space
so people do this for guns giveaway
giveaway for guns um
there's a lot of people who are like
really passionate about guns and
ammunition and things like that
there's also ones that are so car is
probably the biggest one
there's houses when i was gonna sell my
house it was right when covid
hit and it was like the worst time to
sell a house and so i looked into
could i raffle my house off and actually
could i get a better price raffling my
house and then there's all these rules
against it like you gotta like
basically like churches can do it and
not a lot of other people are allowed to
do this
um so yeah so basically there's there's
a lot of these that you wouldn't
otherwise expect
and uh yeah i've seen i've seen somebody
doing this with cars at a pretty big
scale
and i'm looking at this company now and
just
i should say by the way i have a friend
or a friend of a friend who's doing this
with cars
and like there was three months where
they were just like oh my god this is
printing money this is the best business
in the world and then we checked back in
six months later and they're like this
is such a hard business dude
it's like you know and so i think that
it's not um
it's like many things where it's not as
easy as it sounds and there's also like
a thin line of like at some point you
you can fatigue out your customers
right you can fatigue out the buyers who
get disillusioned that they're not gonna
win
or you um the ad costs go up and then
the business all of a sudden went from
working beautifully to kind of upside
down
yeah okay so this business they're doing
five sorry six million
nearly in profit and they're only
selling the asking price was 24 million
dollars
right so there's so they're asking five
times profit
one times revenue and there's a reason
for that five times profit to me is
actually quite good
for this kind of business i would think
they would want to get way less
and it looks like the only true asset
they have is the website which
anyone could copy probably with 10 grand
maybe 40 grand
then they have a 300 000 email list and
then they have 300 000
sms subscribers which is baller
so is that good yeah that's huge and i
bet that works extremely well for this
because if it's like
basically hey look at this amazing car
do you want it and you're just sitting
there on the bus it's like well i'm not
doing anything else right now
click and you go enter the enter the
giveaway each time i could see how that
hook would work because
sms you know sms gets like an 80 open
rate and email gets like an eight
percent open rate so it's like
it's you know 10 times better so i
similar to your thing
i don't really have any ideas for this
because i think they're kind of
limitless
but i thought it was interesting and i
wanted to bring it up because i think
this is like a little
bit on like the dark side of the
internet that not a lot of people know
about
and i thought it was crazy fascinating i
don't think it has to be like
bold.org incredibly ethical uh
straightforward there's no tricks i know
the guys who run it it's i'm a customer
of theirs
it's it's how was we like okay so
somebody's there for bold they're trying
to get a scholarship right they're not
thinking about the hustle
maybe hustle's like auto checked in
something which is like share
share your information with our
marketing partners who make this
possible you know and you're like great
now you got their email on a list
did you see that they performed yeah
they were okay
yeah yeah yeah so okay so let's do the
math here so let's just say that and
all these numbers are i'm making up
hypothetical let's just say that i
acquire a user from facebook for two
thousand or
two two dollars and they have a fifty
percent open rate that means i'm
spending four times four dollars for a
fifty percent
open rate or sorry for a it works for a
reader yeah for a reader and and let's
just say that like the way that we used
to track it
is that we we knew right away if they
read the first five the likelihood that
they're gonna stay for 18 months or
whatever it is was very high
yeah okay so i paid four dollars for
that 50 person we'll call it
we call we have a gold silver bronze
that's like we
we internally so a gold user just cost
us four dollars right okay
now let's just say that on bold.org i've
got to get
10 people but i get those 10 people for
a dollar
and one of them becomes a gold reader so
i just paid
one dollar for a gold reader so you get
a lot of volume
but you make up for it because it's
cheap right
right and um and you basically just set
your rate with them or they they just
have a rate and you have to figure it
out
like do you say this much per lead or
how does it work a lot of these
companies are
the smart guys they don't have a set
rate they give you a ballpark
and then they but they first want to
hear what's it worth to you yeah of
course
and then they try to sell you uh they're
like oh okay these are worth this to you
okay we're gonna set it at this budget
and then what you do is
you go out and do it for a month and
then you renegotiate
yeah i think this is a fascinating
business i also think that giveaways and
sweepstakes are just a
useful marketing tool so even if this is
not your business oh by the way i just
went i just went through it i just went
through the funnel while we were talking
yeah so by getting halfway through the
scholarship flow i
earned 50 bold points and then you can
get five more bullet points
for signing up for this you can get 10
more bold points for doing this
and how big is this bold thing bold.org
like the
like how big is this business well i
don't know i i mean they never told me
the revenue i think are pretty baller
business
i imagine it's very very very pr if you
told me it made half a million to a
million a month in profit i wouldn't be
surprised
this is like somebody who has a black
belt in the internet they're like ah
here's what
that's this guy dennis man this guy feel
good feel good story
on the front end dope lucrative business
model on the back end right i
love i love this this is clear this is
an internet black belt
yeah it's it's amazing this is a it's an
amazing thing and i wanted to
i just had to bring this up because this
is one that like this doesn't sound sexy
right
um this doesn't sound like like oh i i
want to do this when i get older but it
just makes loads and loads of money
another one is omaze o-m-a-z-e have you
heard of that
yeah that's like it's like a platform to
do raffles and whatnot right
yes but they act like it's a charity
thing so it's like
like snoop dogg's going to give away a
car and all the money
or like some of the money goes to
charity or something like that in
reality omaze gets their cut
in the same way that i've just outlined
the three business models yeah
uh that's fascinating i feel like we
could do an even deeper dive on this
because i feel like you just touched on
like 10 interesting things that uh
that we should probably like i feel like
we should do a separate episode all like
kind of like the deep dive into this
sweepstakes giveaways thing i bet that
would go pretty viral honestly
and i'm going through the the the bold
flow
they asked so many questions like what's
your estimated current annual income
what's your dream like what job do you
want to have how much money do you want
to make uh
how many how i mean they asked so many
questions
so i asked you for money right now would
you say yes yes okay great
so like basically what they're doing is
they're getting like crazy amounts of
qual
it's all about enriched enriched lists
basically yes
and it this is crazy uh all right i got
another one
have you seen this company nugs yeah
they changed their name though yeah they
well i think they have like a parent
company and then the product is called
nugs so the product parent company's
called
simulate i think um and that's because
they're basically simulating
real meat and so nugs is one it fits
into this category of
like alt alt meats or fake meats so you
have beyond meat you have the impossible
burger
and what nuggs is doing is nugs is
chicken no by the way they changed
the product's name is different what's
it called now oh really
it's not called i just googled nugs i
can't even find it
uh i think it's still called that it's
nugs with two g's
no if you go to simulate.com you'll see
the uh the product and basically
it says the tesla of chicken um oh my
god
and so so you can see that the like if
you go to their pro
go to simulate.com nugs so it says the
original nugs forty five dollars
for a box and there's fifty people for
two boxes and there's 50 pieces of brew
box so basically 45 bucks for 100
nuggets
and they have two flavors there's
original and spicy
and and their landing page is like
kind of like cheeky like the instead of
saying it's good for you it says
kills you slower this is higher in
protein and lower in fat than animal
based nuggets
um you know you can get this fast here
you go blah blah
so they started as a kind of like a d2c
brand type of thing
but i think either during covet or or
before right before covered they
switched to basically just selling to
retail
and so i saw them because they raised 50
million dollars recently
like a month ago or something like that
and um the guy who's behind this
is this guy uh he's a young guy ben
pasternak
and um this guy's pretty clever so he's
he was really young he i think when he
was 18 or 19 he had built this app
called monkey
i don't know if you ever saw it it like
it was kind of chat roulette foot for
your iphone
so you'd get on there you'd randomly
match you in a video chat with somebody
else and then you could like skip to
somebody else
and um i saw this because i was like oh
that's kind of clever like i don't think
it's gonna work but like
i like the branding um i like that this
guy was able to like kind of game the
app store chart so he was climbing the
charts
but you could tell this wasn't a sticky
product uh so i
you know reached out to him had a chat
super smart guy
how long ago was this maybe five six
years ago
wow so he might be 20 i don't know he
might be 21 22 now he was like 17 at the
time something like that i don't know
somewhere around that range he was like
17 or 18. and um
i remember just thinking wow this kid's
like a superstar or the future superstar
i think
i gave him the highest compliment i
could give him which is i didn't even
recruit him
i was like you know what you're ready to
just do this on your own like don't
don't even waste the time coming and
working inside my thing like if we work
together we build one company if we're a
part you're going to build two companies
since but i really like the guide
and remind me of this question so i
actually don't even really want to talk
about the fake chicken nuggets thing
although
good market to be in i would say um the
part that i think was interesting is
like
i meet a lot of people like this who are
like clearly special
gonna do big things it it's probably not
their first app like it's probably not
monkey
but it's probably nugs it's probably
their second or third attempt
that's gonna hit and it got me thinking
like
could you basically as a founder like
buy an option
could you buy options could you buy
future contracts on founders and what
does this mean so
most people when they think of this they
think isas oh it's an income share
agreement
i'm not even saying that i'm saying
there's a it's it's
that juicy of a market of founders like
this that you could actually just sell
the right
to invest in my next thing yeah because
because otherwise it's hard to even just
keep
tabs on people you don't know when
they're pivoting you don't know when
they have a new idea you don't know when
they're launching
and you're like dude i believe in you if
you were just gonna start a new startup
i'm in for 25k like no questions asked
just put me in the precede round so it's
like
the lower valuation of the of the others
so i think i would have paid
10 grand just for the option to invest
in this guy's next company over the next
five years right so i think you know 10
grand 25 grand
dude i think you could tell to investors
just the
right of first refusal basically to
invest in my future company
it's not equity it's not an income share
agreement i don't even have to start
another company
but i think i think real investors would
basically have a budget of
maybe single digit millions of dollars
where they're just placing options
there's buying option contracts on like
high performers they see in in the tech
industry
to say hey next time you start your
thing i get the first dibs at investing
so this is something i'm i'm looking
this up so i
i think it was it was either jerry
seinfeld or joe rogan
was talking about the 90s in tv and i
believe they were
telling a story about roseanne um and
how
basically they're like it was the golden
age of tv because even though the
content nowadays is probably better
but basically if you wrote like an okay
script or just a pilot
or a screenplay a a company would pay
you a quarter of a million dollars a
year and
the only thing that you had to do was
not do it like they bought the option
and they'd be like yeah
sometimes we would they would just buy
the option and we would never even do it
so i was just getting like
a quarter of a million dollar a year
salary for three years and i didn't have
all the rules
just don't do anything right it's like a
retainer or like kind of like a
it's like a it's almost like an advance
on a book deal in a way
and i don't actually know i i know
nothing about
hollywood and i don't know if that still
exists of course it does
but i think it was more common then when
cable company or when cable's crushing
but i think this is actually a fantastic
idea
and basically would be like i have the
option let's see how would it work
anytime you raise money
or anytime you own more than 50 of a
entity i get i get the i get first round
refusal
i think it's a really really great idea
yeah like i don't know how the math
works exactly but i can sort of see like
it turns entrepreneurship into a job um
and it gives you a floor
so let's say like i think if i did this
i think if i went and i said hey
um you know hey i left my job at twitch
by the way i
as of today officially am no longer no
longer employed i'm a free
free man um congratulations i wasn't
sure when we were gonna bring that up
thank you yeah yeah so if i was
basically like hey
i don't know when i'm going to start my
next company but um you know if
anybody's interested
here's a place where you could go here's
a website you can go to and you can
basically buy
a future option on being in the precede
round so let's say
um i'm selling slots for
i don't know 15k a pop so 15k for your
right to invest in my next round
and i basically sent that to every vc or
every seed fund i know
i think i could probably get 10 people
to opt into that they'd say cool i'll
give you 10k right
i'll give you 15k right now easy and um
in the next 18 months i'm going to be
thinking about a business and then when
i'm ready
you get the first dips and you know the
round might be like a
three million dollar round and you get
to invest in this and so i get 150k
floor to go do my search for my next
business
and they get they get the guaranteed
locked in deal flow
and i don't know maybe i'm maybe i'm
underpricing it maybe it could be more
or maybe it's an annual thing i'm not
sure but like
i'm pretty sure out of a fund you know
they would allocate a few hundred
thousand dollars to placing bets on 25
founders that they're like yeah i'll
i'll be in your next round
can you also do this so uh did you pay
attention to what happened with the ncaa
today
no what happened so i i wish that you
would have because i don't actually know
the full details
uh but yeah me neither
um the the supreme court basically well
i know what happened so the supreme
court
here's the headline the supreme court
unanimous unanimously sides with former
college players in dispute with ncaa
about compensation so basically i i
don't know if there was any firm rules
but basically um the doors now open for
how ncaa athletes can make money
and when i think of options i mean i
definitely think uh athletes are the
best
yes definitely so yes so basically the
thing here's what i'm reading here it
says
the unanimously ruled that the current
cap
on education-related benefits such as
scholarships graduate school musical
instruments tutoring
violates federal anti-trust laws and
must be lifted so that means that
this is just for uh there was limits on
how much you'd be compensated for you
know tuition room and board stuff like
that
um so that's lifted but it's not yet
salaries for athletes but that's coming
because they've also passed
there's also been a rule passed around
the athlete themselves being able to
monetize their name and likeness
you know like i'm in a i'm in a college
town in north carolina well
the local car dealership can like use my
name and face
on their ads and i can make money from
it um you know things like that that's
that's what's coming so i think there's
definitely a big opportunity there
uh just in general yeah so here we are
future contracts
yeah i'm on board i think it's great
okay cool i don't have anything else to
say except
great last topic i want to give you some
predictions
um so i've been thinking about this and
i think you're bold for doing this by
the way you're making it very easy to
look stupid
well that's the beauty of predictions
it's like a
you know the best predictions i think
most predictions when you're wrong
people forget unless you're scott
galloway uh you know when you're small
when you're small you should make
predictions because uh the cost of being
wrong is very low but the cost of being
right all of a sudden you're the guy who
called it
um you know like it's like my clubhouse
thread like
as that gets proven right then it'll be
like oh he called it but if i was
already big then if i was wrong it would
be like kind of like everybody would be
waiting to rub it in my face
um okay so let me let me run you through
what i think the next
um when did you come up with these is
this like some twitter thread you're
going to do
yeah i'm going to do it as a thread but
i was just one day so i could see the
timestamp on this 11
27 pm so this is the type of [__] i
think about at midnight
um and i started typing on my phone i
said i said okay what's apple becoming
because i see apple apple's shifting
into like
health in a pretty big way with these
like wearable devices
and so let's just say apple which today
the core benefit is they give you this
ultra personal device
you're a little personal super computer
that's going to help you with life so i
don't think the next apple is a phone
company i think the next apple
the next apple which is gonna be a
trillion dollar company that has
uh that gives you kind of like a a
consumer device
i think it's gonna be a healthcare
monitor i think it's gonna be something
that is
gonna be measuring what's going on
inside your body and feeding that data
back to you
and so that's my that's my prediction
the next what the next apple looks like
not a phone company healthcare
monitoring device
next facebook okay facebook today people
think facebook is an app it's a social
network it's where you go
right on a news feed or you post photos
i think
facebook the core of facebook the guts
of facebook
is basically cameras it's content
sharing so it's basically
photo taking or video taking and sharing
with people who you care who you want to
share that stuff with
and that's why instagram is something
they own whatsapp et cetera et cetera
and so i think the next facebook is not
gonna be an app
it's not gonna be another social network
it's gonna be some kind of hands-free
always-on camera so it's gonna be
something you wear either glasses
or a lapel or something a [__] drone
that's floating above you at all times i
don't know what it is
probably glasses because it's at your
eye level and it's going to be basically
like a super memory
so it's going to let you capture photos
and videos of whatever you're looking at
hands-free and instantaneously and then
once you've captured it be able to share
that or save that as like a super memory
for yourself or
with any friends and so i think
anybody's trying to create the next
facebook
you're not creating an app where you add
friends you should be creating
a hands-free camera that makes it way
easier to capture content and it'll
bypass facebook altogether
because that cat that place where you
capture content will just be for sharing
similar to a snapchat attacked facebook
snapchat made an app that when you open
it
the camera's on right away and you take
the photo first and then you just share
that photo with somebody so they skipped
the whole facebook process
so i think that's what the next facebook
is a hands-free always on camera
next amazon this one's stolen from mark
laurie next amazon
so amazon a place to shop it's not going
to be a website where you
uh where you type in a word and then you
get 5000 images as a result and then you
got to sort through them
the next amazon is conversational
shopping in your house
it's just saying what you need and
having something go get it for you
um so basically it's just saying hey uh
we need more
pee pads for the dog and it says you
want the same ones as last time i say
yes and then it's
boom it's ordered right i didn't have to
type anything in
didn't have to enter a credit card it's
all on file and this is a hands-free
voice assistant that helps me shop for
things
and when i don't know what it is it
could say i could say hey
um i need a you know the best camera for
my webcam
and it could say something like do you
want the ones that most of the youtubers
use do you want the ones your friends
bought the most
or do you want the one that's the best
value or the highest price and i'm like
ah
what do my friends have sam has this one
would you like to
ask him how it is yes it asks sam and
then sam says it's amazing and then i
buy the thing right
conversational commerce something like
that that's the future that's the next
amazon
next netflix okay next wait you skipped
over 7-eleven
oh i'm going to do 7-eleven two okay
7-eleven the next 7-eleven what is
7-eleven it's a corner store that has
like it's a little local convenience
store this one's easy
this one is it's a cloud corner store so
you don't need a real location it's just
going to be
500 square feet that's within one mile
of you
it might be in this back alley place it
doesn't need a good location and it's
going to deliver to you
with small lightweight drones so small
little pass
a small little carrier drone gonna bring
you something within 15 minutes of
ordering
no human being involved and the whole
the whole 500 square foot place doesn't
need good real estate
and is going to be automated so that um
you know when i push the button to order
it there's no human being in the place
it just pops out like a vending machine
the drone takes it straight to me and it
lands on a little landing pad that i
have in my front lawn
for uh drone deliveries and as soon as
it's there i go outside i pick it up
okay and then uh keep going i'm just
listening i think this is fascinating
i'm i'm taking notes i'm going to tweet
those just like
as you're talking so i'm going to steal
your cloud you're still my thread okay
great
um all right the next netflix net next
netflix i think is going to be
um one of two things one
is it's either in vr and it's more like
it's a
hybrid it feels like a game so you put
the headset on you enter the world and
then you walk around and you sort of
experience a movie
um so it's either vr or or because i
think i'm not sure about that one
or it's machine generated movies which
is basically something personalized to
you
so right now a movie is like a really
specific story
that gets filmed edited produced has
actors blah blah
i think you might be able to just sit
down and be like i want something that's
like breaking bad but with casinos
and then it just generates it just
machine generates
a movie for you uh based off of
basically it's like a mashup and you've
seen this with music
so google released this thing called
composer or whatever it's like this ai
that basically writes
classical music that sounds like it's
made by bach and mozart
and um and it's basically just it's just
taking all the
stuff that exists out there it studies
it and then it creates remixes and
mashups of all those things in a way
that's
maybe it could be one time it's like i
get this thing and it's like a one-time
movie for me
um that could be kind of crazy remember
that remember that band girl talk
yeah mashups yeah yeah i used to love
those things man
i still work out to that that's my go-to
for working same i love that too it was
like feed the animal or something like
that
that's yeah that's a great track yeah i
love that [__] i'm on board
so similarly uh the next pornhub is not
a website you go to
and you see a bunch of like pre-made
porn movies i think it's all deep fakes
so i think you just go in there and you
just have a fantasy so you put on your
vr device
and you just think of something you want
to see you think oh
uh mila kunis um she's my waitress
go and like it basically deep fakes a
porno uh for you with
mila kunis's face on it if you don't
know what a deep fake is it's a
um it's a computer generated movie where
the
like the actor on the screen was never
there like it'll make obama look like
obama's
you can make obama go to a baseball game
and pee in the crowd right because
uh it could just take any which by the
way like that put obama's head on it it
looks real
that that's why it's scary it's yeah
fakes are scary
uh for many reasons you're not gonna be
able to trust video anymore
because i agree video can be faked just
like any photo can be photoshopped
any video can be video shopped now um
all right last one
uh the next dominoes so the next pizza
company is going to be
a fleet of self-driving cars that are
just going around that have an
oven baked in the in the trunk so um
your food is going to be baked fresh
it's going to arrive to you with a
driverless car and you're going to hop
out uh you're going to come out to the
front you're going to meet the car uh
and
it's going to pop up with the trunk and
there's going to be a pizza that was
baked
during the drive time for you basically
like like
like a mobile food truck type or like a
food truck that which by the way
when our friend our our friend gagan
launched this company called sprig i
think it was only in san francisco or
maybe san francisco in chicago and he
raised 60 million dollars all this money
he launched it early though 2014
and that was what he goes he goes i want
to have ovens in the car that's the
future
and i actually think he was right i just
think that it was a little early
totally true uh this guy david langer he
started zesty it was like a
food catering company that was like
super fast growing at a time and i asked
him i go oh yeah
what do you think of what do you think
food delivery seems hot he goes he just
jumps straight to the end he goes
yeah the the end answer is cars with
ovens in the trunk
um it's really the only solution that's
going to work like at mass that will
replace like kind of like the whole
uh infrastructure that exists today is
when you can get the food to be
baked in the car and kept hot in the car
and ready hot
coming out of the car and when you do
that there's it also reduces the
delivery time because you're not going
to a brick and mortar place
loading the food into the car and then
driving to a place you're just
constantly circling around an area
and as you get in order you pop the
thing into bake and then when it's ready
you're at the door so there was zero lag
time so deliveries get faster
and fresher so this is my segment of
basically sean time travels to the
future because if you think about it
right i'm born in 1988
not that long ago 88 to like
96 there's 97 like i remember that time
michael jordan was like winning
championships during that time
there was for the average person there
was no internet or we were just
just getting like aol chat rooms and
[__] like that right i was
putting aol cds into the computer
that was in my computer room because the
house had one computer
right yeah we all had computer rooms
remember we had computer rooms exactly
and so then like that sort of changed
over time it's like oh
computer rooms become laptops laptops
become phones
phones have freaking like hd video
streaming
live you know basketball games from the
internet now to my phone and i'm
watching that while i'm in my car
like that seemed absurd i remember
actually even the first time i saw
someone reading on their phone and i
used to have like a nokia you know like
the old phone that had snake on it
and i was just like what reading on your
phone who would want to do that like
the text is so small and so shitty like
who would ever watch a video on their
phone or who could type who could like
because this is when they just had nine
ten ten
ten buttons and you had to like click
three times to get another letter
yeah what was that thing called or you
had to like uh it's like smarter text or
some [__] like that
yeah yeah yeah and it would autofill
yeah i was like but that seemed so
far-fetched and that was in that was not
that long ago like i was like that was
like 20 years ago
and so in 20 years like kind of some
amazing things have happened so if i
fast forward 20 years
these things that today sound
far-fetched it's like
that's gonna happen because it's the
consumer benefit is there
you know if the delivery is faster and
fresher people are gonna do that
right if if shopping gets easier i don't
have to search and read and be
at a computer i just say what i want
when i want it and i get it like
you know i get it in less than an hour
that was the part i forgot to say it was
that
prime two day delivery is gonna seem
like incredibly slow
like ordering everything from amazon is
going to be just as fast today
as today ordering doordash is going to
be it'll be here in 45 minutes
oh you need a hdmi cable here push this
button it's here in 40 minutes
delivered via drone and so um yeah i
think that's what the future looks like
so that's my time traveler section what
do you think
which one did you think i was most on or
off about you're i think you're most on
about apple i think you're most off
on so i gave you facebook the hands-free
camera always i'm looking at it now yeah
i have all the notes
i think you're on about apple i think
amazon you're not totally right
facebook was um what was facebook
the hands-free always on camera instant
capture of anything that's going on in
your world you don't need yeah i think
you're wrong actually about that
capture i think there's a world where we
go in reverse and we get less
tech driven and people want less contact
with people i think i think it could go
the other way so i think you're wrong
about that i think you're totally right
about apple
uh 7-eleven i think you're right netflix
i actually think you're right
pornhub i think you're right domino's i
think you're right
i think i'm right on all of them bro i
think i got them all right it's just a
question
the the great quote is don't confuse a
clear view for a short distance
i love that quote that's like one of my
what's that mean
like imagine you see something on the
driving you see something on the horizon
it's like oh there it is
it's just because you see it doesn't
mean you're near it right objects in the
front view are
maybe further than they than they appear
and that's what often happens with the
future is
you can kind of see what the world's
going to do and what it's going to look
like but
you overestimate how soon it's going to
come and then you get sort of
disillusioned and then eventually it
does show up
you know i think i think it will be
capable of that i think the thing is is
what i've learned reading history is
that it typically repeats itself
or like what's what's old becomes new
and what's new becomes old and it goes
back and forth
and when we were now that you know
people our age
and young a little bit younger are
always connected i think
it's going to go the opposite that
they're going to be one they're going to
want a less connection
right you know that's why motels like
motels in america are booming right now
because it's like nostalgia
and it's interesting again and so i i do
think that the pendulum does swing
but um i don't know i think both happen
at the same time i think that
um the world i agree with on-demand and
more digital and then people crave
physical experiences and both exist at
the same time
uh it's sort of like the clear view
short distance thing a great example of
this is like
webvan you know year 2000 it's like oh
grocery delivery online what if you
could buy your groceries online instead
of through a store
and then it gets all this hype then it
crashes and then for like 20 years
nobody nobody really touches this nobody
really tries this again
and then um and then here we are with
instacart is a multi-billion dollar
company taking that same idea but
putting it in a fresh way with
new tech tools and technology like
mobile phones yeah i i
i'm on board with a lot of that all
right um we should call it here
and uh yeah all right that's the end of
the episode
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back